- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians.
Hello, Paige.
- [Paige] Hi, David.
- [David] Today we're going to talk about
identifying subjects and predicates
and in order to do that, we
shall begin with a sentence.
Paige, would you read
me the sentence, please?
- [Paige] I bought a crate of goblin hats.
- [David] Thank you, Paige.
So Paige, do you think
that's hats for goblins,
or hats that make you look like a goblin?
- [Paige] Well, I bought it, so I can say
that it is both.
- [David] So we could go either
way is what you're saying.
- [Paige] (Laughs) Oh, yeah.
- [David] A sentence is
kind of a like a car.
It's got a lot of different
parts, like an engine,
or wheels, or a body, whatever.
A sentence is very much the same way
and you can divide up
a sentence into parts.
Today, we're going to be
dividing up the sentence
into subject and predicate.
Paige, what is the subject of a sentence?
- [Paige] The subject
is a noun or a pronoun
that is doing the action in the sentence
or performing the verb.
- [David] What does that
mean to perform a verb?
- [Paige] Right, so a verb
isn't always an action, right?
That's why I wanted to clarify.
- [David] Mm-hmm.
- [Paige] Because you
can say, "I am happy."
Am is a verb, but that's not
an action that I'm doing.
- [David] Right, you
can't just actively am.
- [Paige] Right. (laughs)
- [David] But in the
sentence, "I am happy,"
the subject I is performing
the verb to be, or am.
- [Paige] Right.
- [David] Gotcha.
What is a predicate?
- [Paige] A predicate is all
of the rest of the sentence
that isn't the subject.
What it really is is the verb
and all of the parts that
are related to the verb.
Yeah, verb and its pals, that's good.
- [David] Let's apply that
approach to goblin hat sentence.
- [Paige] Mm-hmm.
- [David] Okay, so I'm
looking for a noun or pronoun
that performs a verb in the sentence.
Well, I found the verb
and the verb is bought.
Who's doing the buying?
I am.
- [Paige] Right.
- [David] So our subject is I.
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] Then predicate is basically
everything else, right?
It's bought, what did I buy?
A crate of goblin hats.
- [Paige] Right.
You can see that a crate of goblin hats
is also a noun, right?
But it's not doing
anything in the sentence.
I am buying.
- [David] Just because there's a noun,
just because there's another
noun in the sentence,
like crate or goblin hats,
doesn't necessarily mean
that it's the subject.
- [Paige] Right.
- [David] So you have to
look for the thing that is
performing the verb.
- [Paige] Exactly.
- [David] Paige, I think
that covers everything except
exactly what a goblin hat is,
but we can talk about that
some other time.
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] That's identifying
subjects and predicates.
You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Paige] Paige out.